can you guys hear
me do you guys hear me am I being
heard am I being heard
guys do you guys hear
me loud and
clear clear and loud
Wonderful Waiting for dirt right now uh
I'm a little late uh so dirt's on his
way he'll be here
momentarily clear not
loud the shaking video view is cringes
yeah
see I I
bet I've always had a habit of like
shaking my hands for for a variety of
things like when I'm excited or anything
like that my brother does the same thing
that's why like it didn't really bother
me I appreciate you guys for coming
through I no this is not
pre-recorded you know as you can see I
don't have my cam on I don't got a front
tooth I don't feel
con I'm too self-conscious at this point
to do that
okay well
will so far so
good he pre-recorded that
response damn
straight I pre-recorded everything I am
everything show yourself we can take it
n I'm
good I am perfectly
good so I wait for uh dirt to get
here what I want to show you
guys
is me playing Resident
Evil real quick let me show you guys you
know if you guys want to to tune in on
this more and welcome
to so here here's uh my playthrough of
Resident
Evil now I'm unsure if you guys can hear
this probably let him are you guys able
to hear that am I
heard
I could probably let him
attack I still don't know how streamyard
does things okay so this is the first
time I've ever played Resident Evil Zero
and uh I really
enjoyed I could probably let him attack
if I take all his ammo from
him
how do I
exchange there we
go yeah I don't trust
you no I want that ammo
back no give me that
ammo you got 15 bullets it's all you
yeah so my my goal right now is to let
Billy do
[Music]
everything shoot I know you got more we
going to use your ammo first there you
go we're using all yours first because
you only got 15 oh shoot him too there
you go
Billy that's my
dude my am most sacred and I got like
880 of it Billy there you go
shoot
shoot there you go
Billy is he GNA
move shoot shoot
Billy oh you don't got no more ammo I
got you Billy Billy what you doing you
got a
knife save point call it a
day there shouldn't be nothing between
me and the safe point because Billy
handled everything Billy was the be oh
my
God Billy shoot
him shoot him Billy there you go Billy
shoot
him shoot them more I'll help
you yeah so that's uh that was my
playthrough yesterday of
uh of resin Evil Zero really enjoyed my
time with it I really did um I'm going
to play some more after the
podcast uh someone
said you're okay to take your shirt off
for the podcast but not show your face
now is a problem man I'm missing a tooth
right now until I see my my my doctor I
don't know man I don't know yeah uh
where's dirt dirt is on his way relax
guys dirt will be
here
dirt dirt is
coming he'll be here
soon we we we we got a little fun show
to do with you guys
today wear a mask I was thinking about
that what kind of mask would I wear
though I'm kind of curious what kind of
mask would I
wear what wear a bandan or a face mask
what kind of mask should I wear though
you guys should a a ninja mask wear a
master he I think a master chief helmet
would like feel
really really
hot the temperature kind of bothers my
my uh the the tooth that broke but it's
not too bad yet the ghost for Shima
mess no I'm not doing black
face
Jesus a Kakashi
mask icho Holo mask Jack a blade mask I
like that I like
that no my girl did not break my tooth I
I felt coming up the
stairs
and I
hit I hit the
like the the the main part of the
porch like the concrete from the main
porch I hit that like with my face
directly and the I hit it pretty hard
thought I had a concussion for a little
bit but I seem to have
survived
let me send dir another one
maybe hope everything's okay with
dirt usually he's not this
long don't you have shows for ice where
you live no I'm not in pain right now uh
you know
I'm not in pain it's just I haven't
built enough
courage to uh turn my camera off you
know see the problem is my whole family
has really bad jeans with
teeth you know my
uh your story nah my my girl didn't uh
she she she's not a violent
person she never really like raises her
voice at
me
what's going on man what's going
on oh there there goes
dirt what's going on dirt what's up
play they they want my camera on
dirt oh they want my camera
on I don't know if they're gonna be able
to bully me into this one man I I showed
dirt a picture it's it's pretty bad yeah
man I mean you know yeah he can cosign
I'm not lying no he's not lying th this
isn't
some some giant
scheme to just get off camera okay that
would have been beautiful though I
should have thought about
that y'all get to look at my
face yeah see actually only my face only
today [__] come on
man you ain't got to make it big like
that actually
actually no we doing that so we got we
got some uh we got some stuff welcome to
the actual talk with the past present
and future G my Coast with me dirt GRE
what's going on dirt what what's
happening what's up my
brother so uh you see all the stuff
going on right now man like Xbox there's
blood in the streets maning like yeah
it's getting pretty bad I will say that
it's getting pretty bad so what you been
playing uh man
um I've been playing you know I played
little Halo the other day that game is
pretty damn good bro uh play little Halo
we been playing um playing some little
Avatar ien been playing like too many
games I need to just focus on one game
but I really went back to uh cyberp Punk
because I never actually finished that
game I I never put much time in it
period um so I've been trying to I've
been playing mostly that lately so yeah
cyber Punk 2077 not the DLC just the
regular
game so the attic is now Darker Than
Dirt I've been playing um I've been
streaming a lot here lately streamed
Resident Evil
Zero uh very I never played those old
like Resident Evil games like I kind of
really started on on
four because I was mainly playing like
Final Fantasy and stuff during that
time but it's it's an interesting
concept man uh I'm really I'm kind of
enjoying it today I was going to stream
Liza
P but I canceled that and after the
podcast I'm going to continue my zero
playr people people tell me I I'm not
built for those old tank style
games they say I'm not built for that
yeah man I those remakes um with two
three yeah they were God say because I I
tried to go back and play some of those
old
ones I tried to play Resident Evil 4 you
know because I never finished the
original Resident Evil 4 I finished the
Remake but I tried to go back and play
Resident Evil
four a little rough man it was a little
rough it's like Resident Evil Resident
Evil yeah so uh there's a lot of uh
stuff going on right now you know we we
got a potential hellblade release date I
think it was like May the 21st or
something like that yeah uh south of
midnight apparently went up on the store
for some reason I don't know if it's a
full download or a placeholder download
did you ever confirm that no I didn't um
because I think I'm not sure yeah I
don't even see it on the store now like
someone said they downloaded all of
south of midnight so I'm kind of curious
on that we got wow stalker 2 release
date it's like September the 14th or
something like that Xbox is just they're
having a crazy year like there you could
you can say what you want about the
perception of you know they might be
going uh to a third party kind of
perspective where some of their games
might end up on other platforms but you
cannot deny that 2024 for Xbox just
looks Bonkers oh Bonkers Bonkers yeah I
agree bro and like you said we're
starting to get some release dates and
that was another narrative the other
people were trying to run with you I
don't have no release dates okay here we
go you guys don't
either well they got release that for
for third party exclusives you know
yeah
third oh my God yeah I think it just
comes down to it like
people people get too in their feelings
when it comes to like what's realistic
and what's not you know when it comes
down to this this is realistic you know
yeah yeah
2024 is just crazy and this is the stuff
we know about you know how the these
companies especially Microsoft they like
to Shadow drop stuff not even including
really the the random Game Pass games
that they surprise us with like Xbox in
2024 is it's
crazy so e rank says he downloaded uh
south of midnight got one of those it's
not time yet messages wow so he was able
to download the game how big is your
download for South midnight it's is it
megabytes or gigabytes because that's
going to matter yeah it is yeah you know
if it's if it's gigabytes that means the
whole game is on the
store absolutely and that's a key
potential that you know there's a good
chance that we might actually see a
shadow drop now I think it's been
confirmed that they're not going to do a
shadow drop
yeah uh but you
know uh Aaron gber also told us that
they weren't going to be at that game
awards in any way shape or form remember
and they they perfect perfect Dart yeah
yeah
so uh no it's small which make okay if
it's small it's a placeholder but it's
still interesting that it's on the store
around this time makes me think that
south of midnight is the fifth game and
it's getting a release date
tomorrow yeah I mean b hey y adding now
you think about it just all these games
coming out now it's just a matter of yo
when are we going to see these games or
when are these games going to drop and
um well like we know for a fact
hellblade 2 is and Indiana Jones and
Stalker 3 is dropping this year that's
three games right there and to borne
that's four those are some games that's
guaranteed to probably drop this year so
man it's it's a lot of fun what do you
think the uh surprise game is going to
be think it's going to be something they
own or something someone else owns
I think it's going to be something they
own probably double finds little smaller
game or whatever I don't know if it'll
be Shadow dropped but I don't think it's
gonna be Shadow dropped I think it's
gonna be a surprise there really I'm
calling it right now South the midnight
tomorrow at the direct getting release
so some game play but it's not going to
be Shadow drop but it's gonna be shown
and then he gonna it's gonna be shown
it's gonna have gonna drop this year
though because I think there's a good
chance midnight gets a release date I
mean midnight comes out this year so you
know I think this would make the most
sense you know do you do you see a lot
of people talk about clar work
Revolution being at the show um no I
haven't seen that yeah I seen some
people think it's Clockwork Revolution
and as much as I would love that I don't
think that's realistic I think people
need to draw their expectations we need
lines yeah I seen some people um
felt felt that Clockwork is going to
drop this year um but I didn't see
people say it's going to be at the show
tomorrow oh so there there's rumors that
it's it's dropping this year well it was
just some regular people just like
speculation regular people yeah you know
just so you know no insiders no insiders
just a regular dudes like yeah man that
[__] dropping this year man you know
that that's it Su it's dropping this
year sucker so that's about it yeah
what's funny is like there's just so
many
people doing stuff for Xbox and so many
people making stuff for Xbox we
literally have no idea yeah that's why I
think that south of midnight is that
fifth game because it is a small game
that would be and to me why put that on
the
store it's it's not a coincidence that
goes on the store like right around the
time all this
happens that' be Fire Man that'll be
fire I would love to see that game
because look man
compulsion I mean I didn't care for we
happy few but I did feel the game had a
lot of potential so to see them make a
game behind Microsoft with Microsoft
resources even though it's a probably
like a high quality doublea game or
whatever it is I'm very curious and I
can't wait to see what they do with it
because remember like we have a few was
a crowdfunding game initially remember
so yes someone said south of Midnight's
been on the store since E3 of last year
uh but I don't think you've ever been
able to click to interact with
them you know did did you see that you
know obviously we this ain't I we we
talk about drama sometimes did you see
all that stuff that reforge and that
website got into yeah I did see it yeah
got any thoughts on that um not really
you know because reforce has me blocked
he blocked me uh last sometime last year
he follows me ironically yeah yeah he
definitely blocked me but I was able to
see the some of the interaction I'm very
interesting stuff
man yeah just like it's like come on
guys like first off the dude that got
fired he kind of deserved to get fired
um you know when you're especially on a
on a channel and and having a position
like that you got to
be I don't even want to say respectful
because it's repor and I know a lot of
people don't like him I don't I don't
really I don't have an opinion on him he
doesn't really bother me too much uh
because I I I don't really see anything
he says but it's just
like if you're in a position like that
like you can't be doing some stuff like
that
like telling like you still Sage your
wife like like at the same time it's
like we got to be realistic with this
matter and to me he was very
unprofessional now apparently he's still
on the assault on his personal Twitter I
don't know if that's true or not uh but
it's crazy it's like look man
like these dudes on Twitter the Red
Dragons the the reforge gamings like
they're just doing this to milk content
they're just doing this to to they're
their their content create their their
engagement
farmers and you guys fall for
it if everyone just acted like these
people when they post this
stuff didn't exist they would stop and
I'm not saying it's anyone in the chat
I'm not saying it's everyone in the chat
I'm saying you know who you
are when you see people just mute them
block them and guess what like I I see
like when I block someone they just
disappear in
existence like I'm just sitting there I
think Dan Cook said a joke like that
once where he's like you be sitting
there you just blocked them and and like
some random girl uh just disappears like
I block my girl and she just disappears
in her car and the car hits something
yeah are you be cover because I I'm
trying hell no you gotta I feel you I
feel you I do feel you to a point but my
thing is like when it comes to people
that's just trying to farm engagement
just just don't give them it because
that's what they
want yeah um see you know but I gotta be
honest with okay I understand where
you're coming from but with me I'm 100%
into this consert War stuff so I fully
expect people
to clip me that has been happening so
far this year a few people clip me clip
my homie Sean clip some things from my
podcast that's fine man as long as you
don't get personal it's cool because a
couple of guys got personal you know
those some guys I don't rock out with
and some guys I will probably try to
fight if I seen them in real life but
you know some other guy you know look
like P clip me but it was about game you
know it's about something I said I said
something that he said you know was fine
we go back and forth all day so with
these guys like refor and those
guys if they're doing it for clicks if
they're doing it for engagement I mean I
guess it is what it is I mean is what it
is but I will say like someone clipped
me today uh because when smooth said a
joke apparently my hand was shaking or
whatever it was uh so that they made a
joke out of it's like a I I'm sorry like
these these PlayStation f
name me Xbox people doing this stuff
yeah like it's always the PlayStation
people it's like look we sitting here
talking about Xbox you know I do like a
little shake with my hand what uh you
know as a gesture I do it on my my
videos all the time so it's just like I
don't see Xbox people be doing that like
I don't see them you know just be
focused like we be over here talking
about Xbox and we just be getting random
stays for no reason I mean you know I
can't play innocent though I do sometime
um go after them
because do you make it your whole
personality no no no no yeah see that's
the point and you only really go after
them let's be honest here D if every
PlayStation Fanboy would leave you alone
and stop talking about you stop talking
about Xbox people would you continue the
thrashing
yes play innocent I can't play innocent
I go after some of them sometimes I do
but but you go after them for the
remarks that they're making yes I go
after them for stuff I'm saying that
stuff
stopped if that stuff stopped I mean if
they had if they gave me no um no
content no stupid stuff to say like I
did a video today about somebody said if
you don't play foam Stars I'm blocking
you I was like what the
hell so that's me say that yeah he
definitely said that and I don't have
nothing against the guy I I really don't
because he hasn't disrespected me on but
you know this is this is console war man
people go after me they make about me I
go after them I mean but I don't I don't
get funny is is you are the Infantry
that's bringing back the the old Skype
War days
like the Skype War days were were crazy
like I never experienced those days that
oh yeah I saw videos like go to your
YouTube video and type in uh Crums side
Sky 4 days like I'm sure people in the
some people in the comment section have
seen it like they they used to be
disrespectful they didn't care it was it
was bad that that's that's when like B
that BG was part of all that Skype Wars
okay I've heard somewhat something about
that but I never experienced it
myself from the angry therapist keep
that foot on them dirt TTS let's go see
but look man you got to realize it you
know this is just not this this Xbox
versus PlayStation these battles man
listen bro when I was young we
had Sega versus Nintendo battles and I
was like the only Sega guy in my hood
like the Sega Master System you know I
was a kid we had um NBA Live versus NBA
2K battles bro like I I told a story on
my podcast I almost got into a physical
fight I mean it's stupid it was
definitely stupid but I almost got into
a physical fight we were playing
basketball NBA 2K 3 NBA Live 2003 both
of the games came out I was the 2K guy
even even when NBA Live was more popular
I was the 2K guy and this guy said NBA
Live is bad I said no it name blah blah
blah and we almost start fighting but
then we realized we were too you know I
was in my 20s then but he you know he's
like damn man all right let's chill you
like 2K I like live fine and we kind of
had to but we was about to fight so it's
like something this tribalism I think is
just end us and I think it's fine as
long as it doesn't get disrespectful
what's funny is I see people on the
internet saying conso War this console
war that it's childish but these are the
same people that's in like the football
spear when I would say their their toxic
[__] is 10 times worse than gaming stuff
like I've seen giant Riot fights at
games it's just like so you go sit here
but the it's like look all fanboyism is
funny until it's not like add you are
100% right I like we've seen clips of
NFL fans fight each other we've seen
clips of soccer games people fighting
each other we've SE it it's unfortunate
but it is what it is and I see someone
say something about WWE bro I was in in
the WWEF versus WCW like War I was a WWF
guy WCW was taking off and kicking WWF
ass at one point and I was bro we were
having hardcore debates like it got
really really intense and Arthur one
said now let's not C console war
[__] is worse than sports stuff no
ain't I can I can pull some clips I feel
like the reason to me Sports is worse is
because you guys are in people's faces
yes bro it's not worse the sports a lot
of the conso stuff is over the Internet
like you you Sports people you in the
face of the of the competition imagine
imagine like a Super Bowl known as E3
where all the Fanboys of Xbox is on one
side all the Fanboys of PlayStation is
on the other imagine be able to Reach
Out And Touch these people that's on
Twitter bro hey author do me a favor
after this show because we're not going
to show anything on here because they
don't like violence on YouTube look up
some some some fights in the uh like
fans just look it up man you will see
fans fighting each other literally fight
like ad just said it's like we're
fighting over the Internet we're talking
trash over the Internet some of these
people are fist fighting in come on man
you must haven't seen it look it up
brother to say War as worse hold up
crazy man you ain't this dude said that
there there's people flipping cars in
sports because of that no you you lying
you lying hold on hold on that really
happen add it wait wait wait wait a
minute bro I live in Detroit right
Detroit uh 84 Tigers won Detroit Tigers
won a championship it's crazy the late
90s I mean I'm sorry the late 80s and
early 90s the Detroit Piston won Pistons
won backtack
championships people be going crazy man
now it is not as bad now as it used to
be like in the 80s and the 90s not just
Detroit by the way when the team won
championships people going crazy they
flipping over cars they I'm telling you
bro the sports stuff is
serious it's serious hockey fan I
remember when the Detroit Red Wings won
in the late 90s here in Detroit like it
wasn't flipping cars but they was like
man I know people ain't never watched a
a quarter of like a period of hockey in
their life they would celebrating in the
middle of the street like you ain't
never seen no damn hockey but they were
just celebrating and people was just
going crazy man I'm telling you this
stuff is serious man people for that got
author you can't bro you cannot say the
console war is worse than Sports people
have a passion for what they have a
passion for I'm not saying it's right
but sports soccer fans like to Darius
say soccer fans bro they be
tripping they be threatening the players
if the team lose like I it's not right
I've seen but it's jacked up man you
know it's another toxic fan base what's
that I think you know what I'm gonna say
these cell phone Fanboys man oh my thank
you for bringing up Apple versus Android
I was in that war at 1 point to I was I
always been an Android guy yeah you I'm
an Android person too and and my
girlfriend refuses to do Android like
refuses I think a I look there are men
that cap for for the console stuff uh
for the for the phone stuff but I see a
lot of women doing it like a lot of
women absolutely I literally have
friends that got broken up uh with like
close uh like not necessarily broken up
they were just seeing each other when
she found out he had an
Android really well you know that kind
of stuff happens with the kids man like
the teenagers like they all love iPhones
and
man I saw a video of a girl said if if
she meets a guy that has a Android she
will reconsider talking to him like
seriously bro the kids got to have
iPhones all of them want iPhones me and
my wife we're we're like we no like
we're Android my daughters they all have
iPhones yeah they they they started to
bring up all the Fanboys Math versus
science Fanboys veg versus everyone else
Fanboys m versus SC vegans vers hey
that's true about vegans I know a vegan
they just think they're Superior to
everything bro that's true about
that yeah man so yeah you know people
just focus on console war you know
what's another one and I know I have a
lot of anime followers the the sub
versus Dub okay oh my God because it's
like if you want to watch in English or
or Japanese with with English subtitles
I never look and I bet you there's good
people right now I watch stuff in dubbed
if I have a chance because I speak
English right why would I not want to
hear anime in
English oh it doesn't sound right none
of that sounds right dude I can't
understand them how does that sound
right we'll just read it
what that's funny bro see look look it's
down there man it's down vegans don't
want that
beef literally and
figur that's
funny yeah but it is what it is bro so
people got to stop acting like this
stuff doesn't exist or your guys are
stupid man you can say the console war
stupid all you want but all you gotta do
is look around and see hey hey adct I've
been at black barber shops I know I I
know I don't have no hair but I do have
a beard I've been in black barber shops
where Biggie versus Tupac discussions
will get really intense like who was
better that's another one another stuff
going on man bro I listen I
um I like Tupac right but I was never
like a huge huge Tupac guy if you say
that around certain people they would
literally want to fight you you can say
yeah Tupac was cool man you know Tupac
was all right what you say like what did
you say Tupac was what I said yeah I
like Tupac but he wasn't all that they
man I'm telling you I this pretty much
happened to me like hold on wait a
minute man Tupac is the goat I yeah man
Tupac cool no he he's the goat I said
he's not my goat what you say I'm
telling you bro it was like serious
conversations man for real and and this
is this is life man this is life I'm not
making up this stuff bro this is some
serious stuff yeah and that that's my
biggest thing it's like let's stop
acting like you know and what's funny is
the same people that will try to to make
us feel bad for console Waring on this
end they're console Waring on another
thing like they like it whether it's
Sports uh whether it's you know the
iPhone versus Apple it's like look
there's a line on any kind of f uh you
know Phantom yep and as long as you
don't pass that line you good even if
you pass that line who really gonna say
much yeah but it's just like I don't
think you should pass that line but
there's a line and a lot of people they
don't know where that line is and a lot
of people confuse that line I was upset
that I was voicing my concern with a
third party direction that Xbox either
is or not going in we don't know there's
too much variables that we don't know
instead of just taking that at face
value I was having people in the
industry saying I'm console
boring so I can't okay so I can't have
an opinion on something that's if you
want to get technical that's criticism
towards Xbox whether being deemed a
console war I'm console Waring it's that
to
me just saying oh you know that's
console Waring it's kind of taking
accountability out of things and then
you have people say well you know you
shouldn't talk about things not
confirmed nothing's confirmed until it's
confirmed and guess what happens when
it's confirmed nothing you say is gonna
change it
yeah yeah you know there's a chance that
everyone's speaking out jez making
articles if Microsoft is considering
doing that they're like maybe we need to
step back and look at this a little bit
more but if no if everyone just says you
know what let's just wait for it to be
approved by the time we get the
announcement it's too
late yeah I mean yeah it's crazy
bro H Final Fantasy
9 supposedly that's being remade oh is
it I didn't hear about
that so what what what's the games that
you're looking forward to I'm kind of
curious
Oh you mean this year yeah you know I
gotta be honest bro I'm looking forward
to everything Xbox has excuse me like SE
for AA that's not really my style of
game I'm not really into those types of
games but I will try it because it's an
Xbox game
pass but I'm Tell You Hell blade is
something that uh me personally I just
waited for man a game like that
because I was obviously around last
generation where they made fun of Xbox
games being too cartoony and Xbox games
looking like cartoons and looking like
crap and you have the world's most
powerful console but your games look
like crap and I'm I'm happy this the
Xbox has a first- party title that looks
like hell blade you know we always had
gears game and forcer games that look
great but nothing that really turned
people heads and made them like yo I
wish I wish PlayStation had a game that
looks as good as that so hellblade too
is that game that I really can't wait
for but Indiana Jones really all of them
bro I'm I'm really hyped for it Sean
Smith said dark skin versus lightskinn
was that a real
war yeah it's funny man you know it's
one of those
things I just saw that
too well you know he right that's
actually going on man I see it like I
ain't black but I see it all the time I
can tell you as a as a dark skinned man
U when I was a kid dark skinned kids I
don't know like black people they could
be so racist towards black people it was
crazy right so like like the dark
skinned kids wasn't as popular as like
the lightskinned kids you know what I'm
saying it wasn't until um I'm sure on my
age but it was a rapper named Big Daddy
Kane who was a dark skinned rapper that
the girls loved and that gave me hope
like yo here's a darkin brother the
girls is own so I got my you know what
I'm saying so so so the girls can like
me too and you know I did okay later in
life but that was a thing though I know
you don't know about that attic you know
yeah I don't I don't you know what's
funny I went to a middle school that was
primarily black people too like oh
really probably like 15 white people in
the whole school oh wow it was it was a
it was an
experience so what what what what else
are you looking forward to playing this
year oh man um far some third party
games I'm definitely looking forward
to uh damn what's dropping this year bro
what's I because I I've actually been
focused so much on Xbox first party I
I'm kind of thought about I kind of
forgot about the third party games this
year like because 2023 was loaded with
third party games what games is dropping
this year hey y'all put some in the chat
what third party game supposed to Dro
this year I know stalker that's you know
still Xbox EX but I don't know man I'm
trying to think about
it I don't know man um I can't think
what gam dropping this year bro I I just
really drew a
blank all right let's see Outlaws yeah
that's one I'm not even into the Star
Wars franchise but Outlaws looks
incredibly good and I really do like
massive entertainment you know under
Ubisoft I love all of their games for
the most part I'm definitely looking
forward to that game a Suicide Squad
yeah I mean you know what that comes out
what next month
I'm going to pick it up uh I Won't Say
I'm super excited for it but I'm
definitely going to give it a shot I
didn't hate The
Avengers I just felt the games as of
service kind of hurt it so hopefully
this one does you know Suicide Squad
being the games as of service doesn't
hurt it as much but yeah I'm definitely
looking forward to that one do you think
after do you think after suicide squad
the uh games service thing for wb's
over um I don't I don't think so bro
like didn't they say they gonna continue
to do
it 33 imoral that's good I may or may
not have played
that yeah that's kind of cool Don Taco
with a$ doll Super Chat actually let me
get these super chats real
quick bone slay with the $2 super E3
should have been crazy if console war
were that bad would have been crazy yeah
imagine like just like constant people
going to jail yeah man that's got a
point there he's got a point there even
when you know when people are going to
be places there's never fight half time
E3 would have been if we really hated
each other a lot of people saw saw you
know the ponies at E3 they would have
been ready to fight right so yeah you
right about that bone slave it ain't
really you know we us be talking trash
on over the Internet bro5 Super Chat
from Donald CH I just uploaded a video
on my channel for games to play in
quarter 1
2024 is it a bunch of uh switch games
though
I feel like it might be a bunch of
switch games yeah so that uh game I
think somebody put it in the chat is it
uh black meth Wukong that game looks
incredible but it's another Soul Style
game and um I'm not into those games bro
I'm just not into those games that's why
I haven't even played Li of
P for whatever reason I'm not into those
games uh I'm playing Li of on stream
right now and it's it's definitely an
interesting game uh but I think when it
comes down to it man this year
people are saying this year's lackluster
I don't think that you know I just think
that people don't expect last year every
year last year was a phenomenon we
probably won't have that for a long
time last year was crazy bro because you
know some of those games you know Co
affected everybody
and 2023 crazy yeah it it was crazy man
not for Xbox I mean let's be real Xbox
going have a great year but it's not
going to be last year cuz when last year
was everyone popping off besides
PlayStation PlayStation really didn't
pop PlayStation wasn't popping off
PlayStation wasn't popping off last year
they just had like one game
yeah
um what is like out of all the games
that's being showed up at the direct
tomorrow what is your most anticipated
game and why well you know like I said
um hellblade 2 is my most anticip at
because like I mentioned I was waiting
for that that style of graphical
showpiece from Xbox first party that's
what I've been waiting for but to be
honest I'm I'm just as hyped for Indiana
Jones and a vow because those was like
two games I'm definitely gonna play and
enjoy um so yeah I'm just you know what
I have to say even though
hellblade to I'm waiting for like H War
reasons just to talk [__] about how good
the game looks a vow is something I'm
very curious about because we don't know
much about that
game and I'm I really want to see a deep
dive of a vow
so I would actually say a
vow I'm 100% with you I think a V's
gonna steal the show oh that's what
that's what Zafar Aman Amad just said I
think yeah I think people don't give
obsidian enough
credit the only thing I'm worried a
little bit about a is is the fact that
they redirect uh they re Envision the
the
game right so I'm hoping that you
know that doesn't affect the overall
product eat fresh guy say I'm not hyped
for any of the games because they don't
have release
dates they they I think this what part
of the reason for the show tomorrow my
man yeah I think everything tomorrow
gonna have a release
date y
because even last year I think forsa
motorport was the only game that didn't
have a release date and that was
probably because it just wasn't 100%
sure if the game was going to be ready
by time and you know
but I think it's just going to determine
you know this year is going to be a very
good
year in a lot of ways even like TV shows
movies you know we got the Fallout game
coming out how do you feel about the TV
show let's let's break this
oh The Fallout
show no the Halo TV show hey bro the
trailer's fire so far the SE the first
season I I enjoyed it I liked it um I
didn't think it was great but I thought
it was pretty good um and but so far the
season two trailers look pretty damn
good
bro I'm just I
think the reach aspect um I have hoped
for
I just want the
the self-correct itself that's
all that's all I care more about just
self-correcting getting things right you
know I think we deserve a a solid show
like I I do I think in terms of
everything coming out to with just the
games
like poor what's that studio called the
one that they're also the fourth game
that no one's talking about like the
civilization game oh are you talking
about that ARA game yeah poor Aura no
one cares
yeah I'm just saying you know it's cool
you know some some people like that
style of game but I'm you know it's I'm
not into them um so I I will probably
you know go go and give me
some like go to the bathroom when that
that game is being
shown so stalker 2 release date how you
feel man you think that's going to
deliver with everything coming
up yeah man I I I think the release date
is a pretty good one September was a 5th
or something like that I think that's a
solid release date um you know those how
you gonna jump into this game oh 100% I
love firstperson shooters I didn't play
the first stalker but so far from what
I've seen of this game looks pretty dope
yeah I'm definitely interested in the
game
um you know like what that Dev team had
to go through over there to see they
were still able ble to make the game and
they need a little bit more time and
obviously that's that's fine um so yeah
I'm looking forward to the game in
September bro
absolutely Jessie B said Xbox conc
creators don't care disrespectful the
way our is discussed it's not about we
just we don't care like it's first off
we got to get to nitty and greedy I care
more about this than probably dirt does
and I don't even really care uh as much
as the game looks cool it's on PC isn't
it I don't think it's on
Xbox so yeah if it's only on PC why
would I care now if it's on Xbox I'll be
a little bit more curious
but I like
Civilization uh you know I I really
liked um civilization the the one that
was for the 360 was a dumb down version
because I can play that with my friends
when it comes to these type of games
it's not that I have anything against it
it's just I know I'm not g to be able to
play that with friends I know that
game's not going to drive really
anything and me personally and I know my
audience don't care about
it yeah I know I have a have to read the
audience bro you have to read your
audience adct knows his audience doesn't
care nothing against the game that's why
I why I mentioned I'm sure someone loves
the game um but it's just not my thing
personally like do you want me to try to
talk like do you want us to talk about a
game um that I know nothing about I mean
we can speculate but
I don't know anything about it that's
that's like if somebody ask me hey uh D
tell me about what do you think about
Pokemon it's popular but I don't know
anything about it I never played a
Pokemon
game I don't I'm not trying to
disrespect anything I'm just being
honest with you you know clearly my
audience don't care about the Halo TV
show because I made a video and it
bombed yeah so like Jessie P you gotta
you know um we understand your concerns
but just me personally addict said he's
not interested in the
game um that's about it man it's not
that I'm not interested I actually think
I would try it DP po put pop in your uh
your YouTube people ask in the you go
there my dude dirt man he he we call
dirt the the second line you know King's
in the front with the
Infantry and dirt's just sniping pools
yes I'mma Be I'mma Be on power world now
I definitely might check out that guy
the 19th dirt you gotta play with me
yeah it looks interesting man so like so
it's like so it's like Pokemon with guns
what's up with that why are people
describing it like
that it's what pokemon would really be
in real life you can eat your your power
world mates uh they're slaves you can
make them do stuff like uh you know uh
tinda stuff
and I'm just thinking people's like oh
Pokemon just you know it's this is just
a more rated R version of Pokemon this
is what pokemon would be if it was in
real life
damn so that's that's supposed to drop
what this
month the 19th oh wow in two days and
it's early and it's early access and
it's a game pass hey man the black
Viking is funny he's he's talking about
power war and comparing it to foam
Stars actually power War seems to be
more popular for whatever reason what
game uh PA is it is it power worldl or
paulwell like the game you're talking
about someone give me the exact
wording power world that's all I can say
p a can I stream myself playing power
world I don't know about that let me get
to these adct questions um we got an
adct question from JD gamer if XBox
spends its time and resources bringing
games to other platforms rather than
rewarding those of us that have stood by
them with exclusives when they had
nothing are they worthy of
support of of those that held them down
when no one else would that's a good
question if uh you know they abandon
ship and open up all the all the rivers
and you know stop stop trying to to feed
us and feed everyone and we were there
when they couldn't even feed us are they
worth the support if they actually go
and do
that um well listen if they put all of
their games on PlayStation and Nintendo
that's that's something that I think
would rub a lot of us the wrong
way a few games here and there because
hell they already have some games over
there right they already have games on
PlayStation and Nintendo as we speak
I remember in in in the FTC trial Phil
Spencer I don't know if he said this or
was through an email but they considered
making Minecraft Legends and exclusive
and they said nah let's go ahead and put
it on other
platforms so look man um it's it's like
this am I me person am I okay with a
couple of games going over there yeah
sure like I said because we already have
some games over there already do I
believe mostly the ACT most of
Activision Blizzard games will stay
multiplatform yes I do will there be any
exclusive ABK games I'm not sure do I
believe all Xbox games is going to other
platforms no I
don't I 100%
don't but you
know I think it just depends okay I
don't
mind certain games as a service nothing
that's like a that's like like a a
pillar I would consider c a pillar H
part of me feels
like if it's a games as a service and
it'll make the platform better it should
be multiplatform and maybe that would
include Halo infinite you know um now I
don't think the story should ever be but
you could make an argument that you know
maybe Halo infant would be in a better
place no that's a flagship that's a no
not that's a flagship though that's the
No No so do you think like what about
gearth no that's a flagship no why it
they're their single players warrant but
you can get the multiplayer faction
there those two games I I just feel
that's what Xbox is known
for now see if thieves go ahead
PlayStation guys ain't gonna play that
damn game they don't like firstperson
games the only first- person game they
play is Call of
Duty do you not consider uh St thieves
like the the flag ship for the Xbox one
no you don't
think for Xbox one that's pretty bad I
mean would name something
outse
um OverWatch can stay
multiplatform which it will of
course uh so you know hey yo n lives
that's all they have right
now that's their that's their ammunition
right cuz all they have right now is
Xbox is going third party that's that's
their ammo right now because they can't
say Xbox don't have games they can't
talk about the power narrative anymore
they can't talk about nothing except for
console sales and now Xbox is going
third party that's all they that's all
they can talk about right now
bro what about grounded should that go
to
PlayStation um
no but I would understand if if that
game
did
um trying to think of
another example once if
uh that Halo battle royale thing oh we
could talk about that the Halo battle
royale was uh rumored to cancel you
believe
that yeah I do cuz somebody told me
about that and like the next day it was
all all over social
media yeah I'm going to say this right
now guys that's that's 100% facts yeah
yeah um I wonder what certain Infinity
is doing because they actually like
somebody came out and said this was
confirmed in 2022 that it was cancelled
way back in
2022 and they've been working with Xbox
they're still working with them so what
are they working on I they I'm curious I
don't know uh Twitter snake makes up a
good point point he says what about what
about
Forza no it's Flagship
bro that's Flagship hell no they got GT
they don't need
forcer that's why I feel
like this kind of conversation is in a
weird space it is in a weird space where
would you consider one thing to go on
the other and not and not the other
where would PlayStation be a violent
excuse but not Nintendo Where would
Nintendo be one but not PlayStation
that's why it's like don't even jump in
this conversation you are 100% right
it's it's a weird space because the way
I
feel honestly if I can get my way none
of them will go right um but I am
realistic and I know I've been you know
too many people that I feel is credible
have been saying it's going to happen a
few games are going to go over there so
I'm just like okay okay um if it's going
to happen
I just don't want it to be full third
party bro that would be a disaster and
and I don't think that will be the case
I do not think they're going to go for
third party I do think they're going to
pick and choose what games will go over
there to other platforms but at the same
time you know we're not getting much
definitely nothing from Nintendo we got
a couple of games from PlayStation so
you know it's it's just one of those
things we go to you know we talk about
like do we want this do we want that all
I can say is people in the chat some of
my Xbox homies never say never read that
Super
Chat hey Ras with the five Xbox is going
third party Human Sacrifice dogs and
cats living together Mass hysteria Dr
Peter Venkman classic movie by the way
um like I was saying never say never
guys because we don't know what these
companies would do because I vividly
remember I brought this up last week on
my podcast I vividly remember some
PlayStation guys saying PlayStation with
never put their games on PC I remember
that I remember that vividly then when
they started putting their games on PC
they said PlayStation would never do day
and date and um I'm pretty sure hell
divers is day and date on PC so Never
Say Never because we just don't know
what these companies will do but I don't
want them to do do what you know the
rumor is you g to play that foam
Stars no I want to play he somebody told
me um I don't know if it was on my video
ear said it was a 6mon time
exclusive would you play that on
Xbox uh if some of the homies want to
play some phone size yo let's go no I
don't want to play that [__] bro yeah I
don't think I would play it on uh foam
stars is the type of game they made fun
of if it was on Xbox
bro I'm sorry go
ahead
thinks that maybe I should try it since
it's on PlayStation Plus at least try it
yeah I mean I would try it but I don't
have PlayStation Plus anymore um foam
stars
is Jesse excuse me excuse me add like
just imagine the foam Stars the same
exact game was an XBox
exclusive what would they be
saying they'd be making clips of me
shaking my hands talking about it
100% 100% listen the game could be fun
um I know Splatoon was super fun maybe
this game is fun just like Splatoon was
but at the end of the day I'm seeing
guys capping for this game for this game
and you guys destroyed Xbox in the past
I'm not hating on foam Stars foam Stars
might be a fun game but these guys
destroyed Xbox for a cartoony games for
games that don't look great um where are
the realistic games
what I'm seeing some of the same guys
capping for this game putting this game
on their 2024
list okay enjoy and the sad part is look
at my comment section you know there's
more there's more PlayStation ban Boys
on my comment sections right now and
there's Xbox ban boys uh they're posting
stuff like hold up let me read a couple
of these comments they're wild
like
uh uh we ain't asking but tomorrow we'll
find out listen High fry Rush about to
be Shadle dropped again but on
Playstation like it's just like it's
crazy you know aren't all these games
come to PS now also I so I guess PC
games got games too like it's just
that's my point with this whole thing
it's like my little
Channel look at all of the people not
even focusing on the games they're
focusing on where they're
going because that's adct you've been
around long enough to know this third
party conversation is ammo for them
that's what it is because they've we've
we've seen your boy Jay du post we need
some more Fanboy ammo like a few weeks
ago he posted that now they have some
they're using it this is more ammo for
them because the console sale talk is
all they
have now this is something else oh Xbox
is going third party they're not gonna
make consoles anymore bro stop
it that's what that that that's the
ammunition right now don't to talk with
the $2 Super Chat y'all not trying to
pull him up with
Bary bar could play that but the thing
is is I have a hard time believing that
Bari would play that if it was if it was
a a
multiplat I don't know why part of me
just doesn't think that I don't know
though yeah no no listen listen like I
let me say this in my video earlier I
mentioned what he said about if you're
not playing the game uh he won he's
gonna block you this is the same guy
that said if XBox once Xbox own Call of
Duty is Call of Duty is dead to
me he said Call of Duty is dead to him
now that's a game that he loved to
play but because Xbox owns them now he
said they're dead to
him I don't know man at the end of the
day
man you know rebirth is coming out next
month I'm playing that [__] like I I
feel like sometimes people do get a
little bit too crazy with with these
uh these uh what platform it's all yeah
we got a$ from aonomus
aamus
aamus dirt and attic let's
[Laughter]
pH we got a $2 Super Chat from Joe AKA
flame shout out to Nate the hate giving
them hope you know crazy what up Nate's
talking about uh outdated information
and all this is out blown out of
proportion and none of this
happens and everyone just jumped on what
Nate said thinking it's true and
everyone's going off outdated
information hey so live Supremacy says
certain Affinity games in development
unknown project with
343 last Expedition so they working on
on a few projects but yeah they still
they are working with
343 man I wonder what they doing over
there cause I play Halo the other day
man listen it's fire fun Halo I had a
good time I I actually I love free fall
I don't like be on teams like that I did
free fall and I'm I'm average a Halo I'm
just average Free Fall maybe I was
playing with a bunch of new people
that's new to the game because I I came
in number one I don't know if I ever
G me number one free fall but it was it
was it was extremely fun though
bro yeah you know first off I wanna
we're probably gonna this is a chill
stream it wasn't really supposed
to be anything in particular you know
there's so much stuff going on so much
drama I didn't want to talk about the
drama yeah so we kind of like just
focused on the
games I gotta play fir
yeah so yeah D tell the people where you
at what you got going on y just dropped
a video today video on the console war
stuff it's about uh you know some uh
Playstation guy drop it in the chat oh
yeah put in there it's about some
PlayStation Guy saying that he has a
source that says uh Starfield is going
to the PlayStation
five um we also talking about reforce
gaming yeah absolutely I'm trying to be
nice on on L's Channel guys
and um also you know I'm talking about
some things that you know like J B said
and some other stuff that some of the
ponies said so it's definitely a console
war video if you're into that thing if
not so
sad that's about it I put the my ladies
video in the chat check it
out that's about it man you know
tomorrow I'm not able to stream are you
guys streaming yes yeah so I'm not I'm
not able to stream my boy Sean 786 is
streaming I I got something to do
important but I will have my onean
Darkman podcast tomorrow evening I
should be able to do it at my regular
time at 6 o'clock pm. so stop by man
stop by sub to the channel if you love
Xbox you love little console war
banter yeah that's about it guys thank
you yeah you know go go support uh dirt
man dirt dirt deserves your support he
he does he does good work man he does
good work thank you brother I on the
other hand you know I've been battling
these dentists that's crazy is I live in
an area like a really small
area so it's
like it's hard to get
people to like people say well call
other dentist there's not a lot of
dentist around here uh I called like up
to like two hours
away two hours away
damn yeah two two hours away nothing n
yeah
I get it I should probably be a little
bit
more I'm I'm a I've been calling them
like every
day because I really need to get this
done yeah definitely bro yeah I ain't
trying to to go and people was like add
it don't worry about that I'm like I
worry about
that ain't nobody want to go around like
having one of your front teeth missing
it's not a it's not a fun show it's not
a fun thing to do right you know I'm
trying I'm trying my best not to to lose
my [__] mind like a bro hey you know
know was rough man he dropped the f bomb
guys yeah because when I what's funny is
when it
happened I like lifted myself up and it
didn't come all the way out it was
hanging on and I was like I got to
finish pulling it because once if it
comes out when I sleep like I can't
choke myself yeah you got to pull it bro
so you right yeah yeah yeah of course
put when I talked to the the dentist he
had me email him he said he doesn't
think it's fixable but we'll see oh wow
D yeah we'll see I'm
not you I am worried but at the same
time I'm trying not to like trying to
be
somewhat like posit POS about it but
yeah it just it seems like if it can go
wrong it's gonna go wrong damn it's
gonna go really wrong but you know we'll
see we'll see uh but you know I
appreciate everyone coming through you
know we had up to like
500 and some people in here man we we we
was we was caking man we was caking I I
really appreciate that guys like you
guys thank you guys don't know how much
you know that that means to to us that
you know you guys come in here every
every day you know you you you really
pull up I can't I can't front like you
guys really pull up every week you know
and the show is growing
consistently and I I I I gotta I gotta
really thank you guys for that because
you know there's a lot of shows that you
know don't get that kind of support and
you make it easier to do the show
because at least I'm not going to like
come in here and you know feel like I'm
not being heard obviously you guys
disagree some of the stuff by say and
that's fine because I disagree with some
of the stuff you guys say there you go
you should have seen them in the chat
when I was playing that that game man
they they were going in on me like
because I guess they think I should play
the game they way and it's like that's
not how this works like I'm not the
greatest of games but damn like give
give me a give me a shot give me give me
an
opportunity they they were going in on
me D I'm not even joking they're like oh
looking atdi it like Cog would say you
he he said I give you an hour before you
quit an hour damn because of the tank
controls you felt like the tank controls
are they're gonna win but they didn't
now to be fair there's still plenty of
time these tank controls could take me
out because I'm only like an hour and a
half two hours in into the into the
game
so it's going to be interesting man it's
going to be interesting uh I'm going to
send you guys over there uh I'm going to
start that stream probably here in the
next three to five minutes you know uh
send you guys over there hopefully you
guys enjoy that
stream and you know it's it's going to
be interesting man it's going to be
interesting there's a lot of things that
we are doing that I think people are
going to really gravitate towards
there's one thing in particular I can't
talk about because I'm not allowed to
it's going to get announced soon uh and
then we could talk about it but like
right now we're not allowed to talk
about it so I'm kind of curious how
people react to that especially the
industry because I'm kind of curious how
the industry is going to react to this
particularly uh so it's it's it's it's
GNA be good man it's gonna be good look
at that stop crying and close the show
get off my back and they they be in man
they they oh man they do whatever they
can like they the moment they feel like
they have it man they they they pounce
at us man they pounce at we can't have
nothing D nothing nothing nothing
nothing
nothing I try to get that nothing
nothing nothing we can have
nothing H it's interesting but you know
want to really thank you guys for coming
through uh next week I don't know when
when is your
thing what thing uh your show tomorrow
what time um probably around six or
seven it depends on um what time I'm
done with my appointment or whatever
okay yeah definitely go you know go in
there and check that out guys like you
know he it'll be after the
show I think you guys you know you'll be
able to sit down and really gravitate
towards that stuff man I think you you
guys will like it I really do and we
gonna be some Bots how bad it's gonna be
oh it's going to be bot PlayStation guys
better not come in
there is it going to be worse if if they
have a good
show if they have a good show it's GNA
be incredible if they if the show isn't
that great we gonna act like it's
great I respect that man I respect that
uh let me go and start this up so I can
send them over to it thanks for stopping
by
guys all right there we go so like I
said uh uh you know I'm about to send
you guys over here I'm G finish eating
because I was eating like really slow
because obviously I missing a too so uh
so yeah I'm gonna finish eating uh but
I'm we're not out of the the ship yet
but we'll be out of that soon but uh you
know I hope you guys enjoy that stream
and don't go on on me too much man you
know I let Billy do everything in the
game like the the the the co-op I gave
him all like I I took his ammo from him
and just sat behind him while he shot
everything yeah it was funny it was
funny I I think I'm going to see how far
I can get in the game we Happ Billy do
everything but uh I appreciate we're
coming through we're gonna send you guys
over there peace peace
out no